In Syria, an airstrike destroys a hospital in Aleppo...
...supported by the international charity Doctors Without Borders,...
...killing at least 14 people.
US Vice President Joe Biden makes a surprise visit to Iraq...
...to meet with US military commanders and Iraqi officials...
...and to show support.
In Austria, UN chief Ban Ki-moon hits out...
...at what he calls "increasingly restrictive" refugee policies in Europe...
...as the continent faces its worst migrant crisis in decades.
In France, protests turn violent in French cities...
...as tens of thousands of workers and students make a new push...
...for the withdrawal of a hotly contested labor bill.
And finally, from Myanmar, protesters demand the United States to stop using the term "Rohingya,"
...for a long-persecuted Muslim ethnic minority...
...and instead consider them illegal migrants.